New tonight.
Republicans want Trump to disappear.
That is the reporting from The Atlantic's
McKay Coppins,
who spoke to more than a dozen current
and former GOP officials and strategists.
But their plan to get rid of him.
We'll have to hear this to believe it.
And I'm going to talk to McKay
about his reporting in just a moment,
because it all comes as Trump
ramps up his attacks
on his new top target.
The Florida governor, Ron DeSantis,
the man many consider
to be Trump's top threat in 20, 24
if he also enters the race.
Kristen Holmes has been traveling
with Trump on his campaign stops
and she is OUTFRONT
Donald Trump
hitting the campaign trail
and pushing back on
criticism of his months
long hiatus
since announcing a third
presidential bid in November.
And more angry
now and a more committed
now than I ever was.
The former president
not only taking aim at his critics,
but potential 2024 rivals as well.
Specifically, Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis.
Ron would have pick up for me
when I hear you my brother.
You know I consider that very disloyal.
But it's not about loyalty.
But to me, it is always one time allies.
Is this Trump country or what?
You have only one choice.
Ron DeSantis for Governor
He's going to be a great, great governor.
Trump and to Sanders
now appear
on a possible
collision course
in a 20, 24 presidential primary.
A rising star in the Republican Party,
DeSantis is coming off a 19 point
landslide reelection win in November.
Obviously, Ron
DeSantis is looking to run for president,
which is fine,
and he'll probably win
New Hampshire right now, without a doubt,
as the centrist
makes inroads with conservatives.
Trump
trying to disrupt that momentum,
claiming the Florida governor
is now trying to rewrite history
when it comes
to his handling of COVID 19.
There are Republican governors
who did not choices.
Florida was actually the first primary in
trying to rewrite history But DeSantis
isn't the only former Trump ally,
signaling they might take him on.
There may be somebody else
in that contest. I'd prefer more.
It won't matter to the Pompeo's.
Who else decides to run?
We'll make that decision based on
whether we think this is our moment.
Can I be that later?
Yes. I think I can be that leader.
Yet not every potential rival
sparking a similar attack from Trump.
Nikki Haley called me the other day
to talk to me. Don't go for it.
But I said, look,
you know, go buy your heart
if you want to run.
As he embarks
on his third run
for the White House,
Trump is facing mounting legal woes
in calls by some Republicans
to move on from lies
about his 2020 election laws
that incited the attack on the U.S.
Capitol.
On the trail in South Carolina.
Trump offering a different message.
This campaign will be about the future.
This campaign will be about issues.
Still,
the former president making clear
he was ready for a nominating fight,
even as he remains the lone GOP candidate
in the field.
For the moment,
we don't do prevent defense.
We just keep defending
and we're going to win and
we're going to win very big.
And Aaron, as you noted,
I was with Trump this week
and traveled with him from New Hampshire
to South Carolina.
And it was really
his official campaign launch.
And it was interesting to see him
almost participating
in a traditional campaign,
something we haven't seen
since early 2016. He stayed on script.
He stayed away from the 20,
20 election lies for the most part.
He even participated
in a small campaign stop.
As we see politicians
do it, an ice cream and hamburger
shop in South Carolina
talking to voters
and his advisers
were absolutely thrilled.
He followed their advice.
But many of them that I talked to
they said
there's still some concern
that they don't know
how long this is going to last.
They have some concerns.
They believe this is how he could
actually reintroduce himself to voters
But will he stick with that?
We know Donald Trump likes to do
what Donald Trump likes to do.
Yeah, absolutely.
All right, Christine,
thank you very much for your reporting.
And now I want to go to McKay Coppins,
who wrote that story for The Atlantic
that I just told you about,
titled Republicans.
28, 24 Magical Thinking.
What an appropriate title,
McKay, given what you write about.
Okay.
So what you write about
is that virtually everyone
in the Republican Party
and you talk to dozens of people,
senior officials, strategists
and members of GOP agree
that it's time
to move on from Donald Trump.
But you say
they have no plan on toppling him.
They are just hoping he goes away.
I mean, are
they just hoping he gets indicted
and that just magically makes
him disappear?
Well, literally, yes.
That was one of the scenarios
that I heard repeatedly.
It was striking how consistently
I heard
the party needs to move on from Trump.
We need to find a way
to get rid of Trump,
that we're way better off with Trump.
But then when I would ask, okay,
what's the plan for that to happen?
It would immediately
move into hypotheticals
maybe he'll get indicted
and his legal problems will subsume
and maybe he'll get bored and drop out.
Maybe he'll lose his attention.
Some people,
you know,
clung to this long held delusion
that maybe he would
become a different person
and now graciously
and make room for the next generation
of Republican leaders.
Contrary to everything we know.
What the consistent Through-line
was, though,
was that
they all wanted him gone,
but nobody wanted to confront him
directly.
There is just this fear
that if they if they go after him
or if they try to rally around
somebody else,
they'll spark a backlash from his base.
And so
everybody has kind of
waiting on the sidelines
just hoping something will change. Okay.
And then there's this this
this hope, this morbid hope.
But I mean, this just brings home
your reporting,
talking about magical thinking.
You write this quote In my conversations
with Republicans,
I heard repeatedly
that the least disruptive path
to getting rid of Trump, grim
as it sounds,
might need to be to wait
for his expiration.
There rationale was straightforward.
The former president is 76 years
old, overweight,
appears to maintain the diet
of a college freshman
and believes, contrary
to all known science,
that exercise is bad for you.
Why risk alienating his supporters
when nature will take its course
sooner or later?
Okay.
Obviously, this isn't just war
but it also is, in fact, by
what we know is
health is reportedly fine.
Could easily do
another term as president,
which is all he would be allowed to do
by law
and that there are
some just sitting around hoping for
that literally.
Yeah.
I mean,
we should also note
that his parents
both lived in their late
eighties or early nineties.
You know,
one former Republican congressman
described this strategy to me
as actuarial arbitrage.
And literally said
that he had spoken to many Republicans
who will
put on the Red
Hat and campaign for Trump
and go up on stage with them.
And then the next day
say, I can't wait for this guy to die.
That's a direct quote.
And so I was taken aback
by how often I heard this.
I thought it was
kind of a morbid, dark joke at first,
but I heard it so often
that it started to become clear
that this was actually
what a lot of Republicans believe.
And it just speaks
to the desperate desperation in the party
right now. It absolutely does.
All right.
Thank you very much, Mike.
I appreciate it.
Hope everyone will read
your full article in The Atlantic.
Thanks.
Thank you.